the entire room erupts in machine gun
fire red tasers rip through the walls
like phaser beams right out of Star Trek
say the words say you want this the El
Camino goes squealing away into the
night it's up to us just saying where
he's headed I like to call it something
better bird's eye view we look straight
down on Walt as he tumbles into frame
lying flat on his back on the floor his
eyes staring up at us lifeless and yet
his final expression
is one of faint satisfaction we continue
Skyward looking down on wall Rising as
high as we can go off this image slowly
fading to Black end of series wow so I
guess there won't be a sequel
but Jesse stays alive
how you feel I feel sad it's great I
mean it's I mean it's you know it's
perfect